super hot super hot super hot super hot
super hot
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and oh god dammit Caden after that okay
enough of that I gotta get out of here
oh my god ooh well that startled the
crap out of me
WASD to move look around with mouse were
you the one who was screaming OH oh my
god whoo it's gone
he's just glasses now he's he he is so
hot that he burned up into just glasses
oh my god someone recommended this whoa
I kind of picked up on that idea but
what that is absolutely insane holy crap
okay someone recommended this game to me
and I blew hi are you gonna move and
imma take him down as well yeah whoa
what happened he exploded
did I karate chop him into the next
dimension what is oh lip against me oh
that's right the bullets wouldn't move
it oh my this game is so cool oh my god
oh my god
can I get that alright okay I already
have again okay where are you where you
gonna be
I'm gonna Maggie what happened
Oh super high it must mean that I'm
super had the deal is off
is that what that
the deal is off that's right Lewinsky
I've had enough of oh I've had enough of
your shenanigans epic oh man oh my god
I'm freaking out oh my god is like the
coolest thing I've ever seen in my
entire life who's shooting me who's
shootin I'm gonna get a gun to the base
please did I get to oh I did get you
this this has got to be like the cool
oh yeah super hot I don't get something
super hot but I don't even care anymore
this is like the coolest game I've ever
oh my god it's so cool if you think it's
fun to look at just try playing links in
the description it's totally free grab
the gun Oh can't shoot me Oh what am I
in the matrix am i becoming the world oh
okay Ritt a good epic couch Oh God dang
in a head it ah super hot super hot oh
my God look at which kiddos just doomed
by here oh my god oh yeah oh we got it
so cool oh yeah so cool yeah oh no dude
damn don't dirty deep I'm gonna get you
hang on I know I'm trying to scream and
I'm excited and trying to be quiet at
the same time because it is late in my
hotel room and my camera has been off
the entire time has it apologize about
that whatever it don't matter
I'm having too much fun we all walked
right into it I'm such an ale you know
what I'm just gonna okay okay do you do
I gotta be able to see you all this is
how we're gonna do it Oh what now
there's almost as if we're moving in
slow
motion maybe they try to lead the oh
that's coming like 44 who epic can I
crouch is that a thing I can do
boom a this is so weird
it's a weird either gonna get me I'm
gonna uh oh
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
yeah that's the stuff oh there we okay I
shoot you in the face I stood you up wet
I need to shoot you in the face and I
shoot you in the face super super hot
super hot super hot I love super hot
super hottest game of the year Game of
the Year coolest game mechanic I've ever
seen in my entire life this is just
amazing
they keep coming Oh what am I gonna do
about uh they keep coming or no looter
debris hey uh where's my gun where do I
get a gun who is that a chair I'm not
gonna use a chair as a weapon hahahahaha
trolling is an art well played game well
wait
ooh my that is a lot of you guys Oh No
where do I get a gun oh my epic dudes
epic dude I need to get a gun before I
shoot you all in
give me well I just get it good yeah
caught that bullet with my teeth then it
kind of went through my teeth and into
my brain but whatever is now what
matters is about the principle thing I
karate oh I remember that you taught me
how to do that oh she is key okay I'm
going to put you in the leg
dammit I hit the wall again I'm gonna
get 208 left who's gonna shoot them all
until they're dead
hey it is two of you down there uh I
can't see you get some no ammo oh I
gotta get a gun I'm gonna shove in a
karate chop that guy in the ball Oh kind
of snuck up on me buddy boy and one down
see can I actually get away with
shooting this kind of big no I cannot
okay it's gotta be careful here
cuz this game is actually kind of
challenging oh [ __ ] it's on oh it's on
oh it's on the wait what is victim I
picked up a gun from one that I had
previously killed dead fish oh yeah
where are you where are you buddy come
on come out out that play oh hello no
ammo time to go Rambo on this sumbitch
actually no I'm not gonna risk it
not gonna risk it cuz I don't want to
lose all of that after doing all of that
[ __ ] is key this is this is she oh I
thought I'd die for a second there I was
really confused her hot this is like the
coolest cool boss fight oh my god oh my
god I'm freaking out this is amazing
guys oh I love this so much I like I
like your modern art here it's very
artistic kill the CEO
kill him why he doesn't even have a gun
why should I should I kill look at the
art that's lovely art I'm not gonna do
what you tell me to he doesn't look that
bad he just minded a little bit my
goodness he's minding his own business
why should I kill him I must take the
noble route doom doom wait is there
actually something over here how crazy
would that superpower be if you could
only if you time so down exactly like
this when you moved don't be a coward
hey don't get back what
hey don't you tell me what to do no
reward
what screw you he doesn't deserve to die
look at him he's just nice I mean he
must be sad because he's got no genitals
out what also that's got to be a
depressing life I don't know whatever I
don't know okay sir I'm gonna ask you a
few questions before I kill you what is
your name what is your cleft what is
your favorite color blue your red
deserved it what yes what was that what
the hell did you just do uh okay what
does that even mean why are the lights
all blinking and who is that you serve
me well okay thank you good sir hey wait
a minute I what I weighed okay I'm
guessing that's what this was all sure
but I don't want to wanna I don't wanna
I'm not gonna screw you buddy
besides when I fall would I go in slow
motion or would I go in regular speed
because I wouldn't be moving me it would
be gravity that's moving me I have no
idea I'm not doing it not gonna do it
buddy I'm just gonna look at this art
mmm these art over here is saw
phenomenal in all its artistic phase I
don't even know how I got in here I
don't know ever now what I'm doing is my
life get back and do your job
how about you go fornicate yourself with
a rake that look makes the lights look
like a heart I have no idea
and what is with this one red painting
what is waving it's kind of a Mirror's
Edge feel all right let's go crore
selves off the ledge why not what better
things do I have to do with my time
hello get ready to die this has got to
be fun everybody ready we super wot
super hot super was at the end of the
game super is this the end
follow superhot the game for more that
was ridiculously cool that was
ridiculously cool I mean that was just
so cool I can't even believe how cool
that was like you guys have got to give
that a try that was just amazingly fun
seriously click the link in the
description below play for yourself if
you thought it was fun to see it's even
more fun to play so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye